here in the United States our stamps
paper money and passports are printed by
our own government but that's not the
case in much of the rest of the world
many nations have these items created by
a single private firm based just outside
of London De La Rue has been in business
for more than two centuries and is known
for offering clients both style and
security Roxana Saberi has their story
Big Ben turns to gold and turtles take a
ride in wallets when designers at
British company Delarue transform ideas
to money
beneath the the pretty designs actually
is it's a piece of critical national
infrastructure economies rest on
banknotes creative director Julian Payne
says while Friday art class is part of
the work week the mission that designers
here face is serious and far-reaching
everything here except the US dollar
stock we've designed Delarue has
designed more than a third of the
world's bills from the UK's sterling to
the Seychelles rupee and the Fijian
dollar and while most Americans use
credit cards 30% of the world's adults
don't even have a bank account do you
have to understand how people use their
money this is um an example of helps
people some people fold money in
sub-saharan Africa and then it's stored
interesting places as well so they will
store it in their clothes in underwear
and shoes under the bed absolutely under
the doormat so they're not going to take
it to the bank so that money that you
create has to be sturdier durable
exactly durable and complex to stay a
step ahead of counterfeiters our job is
to mate Lisa on economic to contain the
company's own team of hackers tries to
copy the designs which often involve
sophisticated security details like
Holograms and ultraviolet imaging we
have point features that designer Steve
pawn says balancing security with
durability and design isn't easy you're
trying to pack a lot of stuff into a
very small space you're trying to be
technically competent you're trying to
be inert if so it challenges you and
you're only as good as your last jobs
jobs like reflecting the Maldives
growing concern about the environment
rising sea levels their low-lying
countries so there's a tree you see
exactly so there's an environment or
message on there 1,000 revere a whale
shark on the back and turtles on the
front and commemorating the 100th
birthday at the late Nelson Mandela pre
don't get much more iconic than that
every country has their heroes and wants
them portrayed in a way that there's
respectful in a way that also is
symbolizes and summarizes in a simple
way that people can just get but
sometimes countries want to forget and
move on when Saddam Hussein fell in 2003
Delarue drew up new Iraqi bills without
his image jumbo jets were flown in and
we printed them and designing the record
time with him but how fast cuz like
within under a year the company also
marked the release of Star Wars the last
Jedi with a limited edition build to
raise money for charity
when designs like these come together
pawn says the payoff is priceless and
what's so exciting about it well it's a
fantastic piece of work it's a great
product and you know as a designer of
banknotes you get to see people holding
your your art everyday you know it's
it's a fantastic thing for CBS this
morning Saturday Roxana Saberi London